tout le monde sait choisir on se trouve
aujourd'hui pour une nouvelle vidéo sur
just dance
alors ouais ça fait très longtemps la
particularité c'est que cette fois on
est sur wiiu
donc pour vous ça change rien mais pour
moi du coup leçon partira de ici depuis
gamepad plutôt qu'ils soient d'air
microïds vous ayez un espèce de retour
assez dégueulasse
alors écoutez aujourd'hui je vous
propose donc quelques chansons ma foi
fort détesté par beaucoup de gens mais
on va quand même faire à savoir la
première assez simple celle ci est la
deuxième moins improvisera halope c'est
parti je lance elle si je vais juste
devoir prendre la manette wii qui se
situe dans mon tiroir merde j'ai
complètement zappé la savard hawks et du
poney les gens disent moi je vous le dit
c'est bon ou donc parfait merde merde
fausse manip ces bons parfait allez on
tue charge un petit coup et on est opé
pop up parfait veut voir la petite photo
j stella ultra sexy c'est parti à
l'offre comprend la probable hockey à
vue sera dr house hier peu de cafard
ok les genres on et mediashow
alors oui mais tu parles
ouais ça vas y toi ouais je suis en
pleine vidéo la huawei ouais bien sûr
alors c'est parti qui s'est passé au
japon fait est là dans son méga surprise
pour vous
méga surprise pour vous assène olivier
delaval moi je suis prêt à affronter
justin bieber hier chez moi à beaucoup
de gens ont dit que ça va aller très
très bien donc je me fais plaisir en la
remettant on va quand même prendre ce
petit accessoire parce que sans lunettes
je ne suis pas fière et et est allée ce
parti qui selon ma fille oui oui c'est
l'accroché t'inquiète pas ma petite
tout est opérationnel assez bon allez ok
je suis des terres alalala wayne là on
va tout péter cowley vous avoir des
petits journal à paraître ici comme un
pokémon sauvages dans les arbres en fin
de vidéo vous allez adorer en fait c'est
un peu plus fort
où
oh [ __ ] je suis en chaleur c'est là tu
dis dans leurs concerts mais comment ils
font bordel de merde et mais qui
chantent ils dansent ils vomissent ils
font l'amour tombe ou la porte
j'ai lâché un petit rôle va d'ailleurs
tu vois ça ok j'ai fait n'importe quoi
fallait faire ça je sais pas quoi je
vais tout autre chose bref c'était super
[Musique]
non